This is the remarkable thing about Action
Essay that sets us apart
is that Herman Mashaba
is not someone who aspires to be a career politician.
He doesn't have the insecurities that most
political leaders
who haven't achieved is something else in life have.
He is very comfortable to say,
I need the strongest people around me
and I'm not threatened by having those kind of people.
Uh, so we have terrific leadership,
but I think very importantly
that leadership
is translated into the building of structures.
Uh, we are literally in all 52 districts of the country,
all eight metros,
and now in 35% of the wards of South Africa,
which is obviously a very tough geographical terrain.